>> HAVE ANY OF THE 42 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST OR NO FLY LISTEN COUNTERED
AT THE SOUTHWEST BORDER BEEN
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES
>> AS I MENTIONED BEFORE I WILL
PROVIDE THAT DATA TO YOU WITH
RESPECT TO THE DISPOSITION OF
EACH ONE.
I DO NOT KNOW THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION.
>> THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY DOES NOT KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THE STATUS OF 42
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME TO OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER ILLEGALLY ON
THE NO FLY LIST AND TERRORIST
WATCH LIST AND YOU DO NOT KNOW
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN RELEASED
OR NOT INTO THE COUNTRY?
THAT’S YOUR TESTIMONY.
>> RANKING MEMBER JORDAN, AS I
SAID BEFORE I WILL PROVIDE YOU
THE DATA.
>> Bill: THAT WAS A STUNNING
EXCHANGE RATHER TELLING.
JIM JORDAN FROM OHIO GRILLING
THE HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
MAYORKAS UNABLE TO GIVE BASIC
INFORMATION DURING A HOUSE
HEARING.
NEWT GINGRICH FORMER SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
HE EITHER DID NOT KNOW OR DID
NOT WANT TO ANSWER.
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR ANSWER ON
THAT?
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS FOLLOWED A
POLICY OF SECRECY AND
DISHONESTY ON THE BORDER.
THEY DON’T TELL US WHERE THEY
ARE SENDING NOW OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE.
THEY FLY THEM IN LATE AT NIGHT.
THEY PUT THEM ON TRAINS AND
BUSES AND THEY LITERALLY REFUSE
TO TELL PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE
GOING.
THEY ARE TALKING SERIOUSLY
ABOUT DROPPING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIREMENTS, WHICH
WOULD MEAN 19,000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS A DAY IS THE CURRENT
ESTIMATE.
THAT’S THE CITY OF ATLANTA
EVERY MONTH.
12 ATLANTAS A YEAR IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
MAYORKAS IS A COMBINATION OF
INCOMPETENT AND IMPLEMENTING
THE POLICIES OF JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN HAS DECIDED THAT HE WANTS
AN OPEN BORDER, THAT HE IS
WILLING TO ACCEPT ANYBODY
WHETHER THEY ARE DISEASED,
CARRYING FENTANYL OR WHETHER
THEY HAVE A CRIMINAL RECORD.
THEY ARE JUST NOT PAYING ANY
ATTENTION.
THE BORDER PATROL IS NOW SO
DROWNING IN THE SHEER NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THEY CAN’T COMPETE WITH
THE CARTELS.
SO WHAT YOU’VE SEEN IS THE
CARTELS GRADUALLY TAKING
CONTROL OF THE AMERICAN
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE FLOOD OF FENTANYL ALONE.
I WAS JUST IN COBB COUNTY,
GEORGIA, WHERE SIX PEOPLE HAVE
DIED IN THE PREVIOUS TWO WEEKS
FROM FENTANYL.
AND THIS IS MADNESS.
AT A MINIMUM KEVIN MCCARTHY IS
RIGHT.
MAYORKAS OUGHT TO BE IMPEACHED.
BUT I THINK ALSO THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO BE OVERHAULED
AND THE IDEA THAT THEY AREN’T
GOING TO APPOINT SOME LEFT WING
ZEALOT TO BECOME THE CENSORSHIP
CZAR FOR THE UNITED STATES
CLEARLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
CLEARLY A VIOLATION OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND MAYBE A
TRIBUTE TO JOE BIDEN’S FRIENDS
IN THE CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY
OR MOSCOW.
BUT CERTAINLY A VERY UNAMERICAN.
THIS TELLS YOU HOW OUT OF
CONTROL THEY ARE.
>> Dana: WE HAVE THE STATISTICS
ABOUT THE MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS SO
FAR THIS YEAR.
NUMBERS ARE STAGGERING AND OUT
THERE FOR EVERYONE TO SEE.
EARLIER TODAY AS WE WERE
REPORTING ON THE NEW POLL, BILL
POINTED OUT THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BREAKDOWN OF REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS
THINK OF IMMIGRATION AS THEIR
NUMBER TWO CONCERN AFTER
INFLATION AND THE ECONOMY.
BUT FOR DEMOCRATS IT IS WAY
DOWN THE LIST LIKE NUMBER FIVE
OR SIX.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK HISTORICALLY
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE
COMMITTED TO AMERICAN
PATRIOTISM, TO THE IDEA OF THE
NATION.
I THINK ON THE LEFT YOU HAVE A
LARGE BLOCK OF PEOPLE WHO DON’T
WANT TO STAND FOR THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM.
THEY DON’T WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THE AMERICAN FLAG AS OUR
PRIMARY SYMBOL.
THEY DON’T WANT TO TEACH
AMERICAN HISTORY ACCURATELY.
AND THEY FRANKLY THINK IT IS
JUST FINE TO BE DROWNED IN
PEOPLE WHO DON’T UNDERSTAND
AMERICA, HAVEN’T LEARNED ABOUT
OUR COUNTRY, HAVEN’T
ASSIMILATED.
SO I THINK THERE IS A HUGE
DIFFERENCE THERE.
INTERESTINGLY AMONG LATINOS WHO
USED TO BE DEMOCRAT THE FLOOD
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IS
DRIVING THEM INTO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND AS I THINK
PROFOUNDLY CHANGING THE
POLITICS OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Bill: TOM MCCLINTOCK IS A
REPUBLICAN FROM CALIFORNIA
DOING A LOT OF THE QUESTIONING.
LAST POINT ON THIS.
HE TOLD US THERE WILL BE NO
PROGRESS ON THE BORDER AS LONG
AS THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
IS IN POWER.
NOW, HE MIGHT BE RIGHT OR A
MONTH FROM NOW IF YOU SEE
18,000 PEOPLE A DAY CROSS THE
BORDER, THAT MAY HAVE AN
IMPACT, THE VISUAL THAT MANY
WILL SEE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> FIRST OF ALL THE REPUBLICANS
WILL WIN THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
I THINK ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THEY SHOULD DO IS SEND UP A
BILL REQUIRING THE COMPLETION
OF THE WALL AND CONTROL OF THE
BORDER.
IT WILL BE WILDLY POPULAR WITH
THE COUNTRY.
70% PLUS SUPPORT.
AND PUT IT TO BIDEN AND PUT IT
TO THE HOUSE AND SENATE
DEMOCRATS.
YOU WANT TO VOTE AGAINST
CONTROLLING THE BORDER?
YOU WANT TO VOTE TO CONTINUE TO
ALLOW MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO COME IN?
THIS IS ALL GOING TO KEEP
GROWING.
THE FACT IS WHEN YOU HAVE THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
PROMISING FREE HEALTHCARE TO
ANYBODY ILLEGAL WHO COMES INTO
THE U.S. WE SEND A SIGNAL.
150 COUNTRIES NOW THAT HAVE
SENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO THE
UNITED STATES.
150 COUNTRIES.
THIS IS JUST GOING TO GET
STEADILY WORSE AND I THINK IT
COULD BE IN JANUARY ONE OF THE
FIRST REALLY BIG FIGHTS BETWEEN
THE NEW REPUBLICAN CONGRESS AND
THE PRESIDENT.
AND I THINK HE WILL HAVE A HARD
TIME SUSTAINING A VETO.
>> Dana: INTERESTING.
THANK YOU, MR. SPEAKER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.